ah the good old days before electricity
did we actually have it better before
the first power plant started running
what if everyone on earth tried getting
by with all their lights turned off we'd
start the challenge with a perfect Earth
Hour sixty minutes of complete darkness
no artificial light allowed would we
reduce the light pollution enough to be
able to see the Milky Way in the night
sky how much electricity would we save
would it help us fight climate change
this is what F and here's what would
happen if everyone in the planet
switched off their lights for an hour
humanity has spent the last 100 years
increasing our dependence on electricity
look around your computer microwave
fridge elevator traffic lights public
transportation everything relies on
electrical power going completely
without power even for an hour would be
pretty uncomfortable so let's just limit
the humanity's light usage hit the
Lights and let's begin
on average humanity consumes 62,000
terajoules of electricity per hour
that's how much energy your gas powered
car would need to drive to Pluto and
back twice 1/5 of all this energy goes
towards lighting that's a lot of energy
and producing it means spewing a lot of
carbon dioxide into the atmosphere
obviously clean energy from the Sun wind
and water don't affect co2 concentration
in the air but they only make up one
third of global electricity production
the rest of it releases greenhouse gas
emissions the thinking is if we gave our
power plants an hour break which
significantly reduce those co2 emissions
on a global level what an easy way to
fight climate change together or is it
turns out it's rather complicated if
this worldwide Earth Hour caught you at
night getting by with the light of some
cozy candles is not the best idea not
only are they a hundred times less
efficient than your light bulb but guess
what they also emit co2 in theory you
could even the score by using just one
candle for every light bulb be turned
off
if you lit up twice as many candles
you'd actually be emitting more co2 what
if you didn't light any candles you
might think we'd emit less carbon
dioxide into the air but you'd be wrong
again
that's not how power plants work the
coal burning ones would in fact emit
less co2 during the dark hour but then
everyone would turn the lights back on
for power stations this sudden increase
in demand would mean firing up more
generators as a result they would emit
even more co2 and this extra carbon
waste would start to trap more heat in
our lower atmosphere possibly speeding
up climate change and that's if power
plants were able to cope with such a
rapid increase in demand in a worst-case
scenario
they'd need to perform an emergency
shutdown leaving us with no electricity
for days when that happened you would at
least get to enjoy a view of the Milky
Way at night a view that light pollution
prevents one-third of the world's
population from seeing so maybe you
shouldn't plunge yourself back into
darkness there are better ways to fight
climate change than turning off all the
lights at the same time for starters you
could try replacing all your
incandescent light bulbs with compact
fluorescent ones or take public
transportation war what do you do to
reduce your carbon footprint